so as Kevin mentioned investing in
transformation I'm really excited to
introduce three awesome speakers we have
Jonathan sham biroon Jonathan's been a
successful operator and investor he's
been in leadership positions at
companies like evite Sony Ning and Zozi
he also founded a company called zygo a
healthy snack company with nutritious
energy bars where twenty percent of the
profits are donated to help improve
nutrition for low-income children so I'd
love to get some of those whatever you
can he's also now coo in an investor at
launch capital seed stage venture firm
based in a few cities across the country
that's been very very supportive of a
lot of Yale companies which we
appreciate next up is will Gabe Rick
will unfortunately went to a school up
in Cambridge called Harvard but he made
up for it by graduating from Yale Law
where he helped start a very successful
and beneficial program called hockey
which is still running very successfully
Will's been both a software engineer a
top companies like hunch he's now a
general partner at thrive if you haven't
heard of it thrive is an incredibly
successful venture capital firm it's
been an investor in household names like
artsy Kickstarter Warby Parker Instagram
and instacart and Will's also been
instrumental in the incubation and
funding of some great companies like
Oscar and maple dorothy jean chang is a
leader in both the VC and PR worlds she
was previously help a leader at brew
meat of the pr agency brew media and
also a PR mentor and residence at
techstars and she's currently one of the
founding partners of the seed fund
Liberty City ventures which invests in
early-stage startups and digital media
digital payments and bitcoin and
blockchain companies so if everybody
would please join me in welcoming
Jonathan will and Dorothy
no this is working great I'm just to
point out Jonathan's on my far left your
far right and this is well I'm Dorothy
if that wasn't clear so we've all come
into investing from different pathways
Jonathan more product operational side
of things will more from an engineering
perspective me more from PR marketing in
my case my stumble into VC was more of a
stumble it kind of happened organically
I happen to have a few friends who were
interested in investing and we thought
about things the same way and we came
together and formed a fun can you guys
tell us a little bit more about how you
ended up in DC know for sure Burke hello
everybody thanks for being here my my
journey was kind of gradual as rich said
I've been in the operational side 20
years in San Francisco at eight
consecutive startups and I love startups
so the first ones in l for love i love
the DNA of the people that are attracted
to startups and the creative process in
a technical environment for a business
outcome so everything about startups
always really resonated with me and i
found about a decade ago as an angel
investor and an advisor that variety was
even more fulfilling and so i really
enjoyed starting to work with more
companies and then lastly leverage the
experiences I've had inside companies I
think they've proven really valuable you
know sharing those lessons learned
especially the painful ones and the
failures and the playbook with a broad
portfolio companies so it was for me a
natural evolution so I can't boast 25
years of track record like that I
about 25 years yeah a little older my my
progression was actually more similar to
us Dorothy wandered into investing out
of school went to Blackstone and left
there to become a software engineer and
was actually in law school at Yale when
we started drive which was more or less
on a lark just seeing a lot of our
friends we're starting companies and
having access to their finance things
just through our existing relationships
and and that honestly just sort of
snowballed into raising an institution
institutional fund and then a couple
more after that it's happened very
quickly which is kind of cool right like
the final you started it and went to two
thousand eleven or twelve lady doesn't
10 late 2010 lead citizens has been
about five years and you've as a
portfolio you have how many hundreds of
companies well we started in late 2010
with like a five-million-dollar like
quasi angel fund we raised our first
institutional fund in late 2011 which
was forty million dollars and then we
raised our last fund which is a third
institutional last fall just 420 million
dollars and we have had the occasion to
invest in about 60 company's total see
cam videos and lunch capital has also
been quite prolific well true and you
know with respect for our elders and
larger we're although older 2008 we
started but with a much more modest fund
15 million and we have 145 companies in
our portfolio but as a seed-stage firm
are typical early investment is 150 k
with roughly the same for follow-on so
we're placing a lot of bets and they're
usually small and then occasionally
we'll have some some big follow ons that
kind of break that mold so just to go
back a little bit into your histories a
little bit more so rich mentioned will
started a organization at Yale called
hockey
where students lead courses on various
areas of web development within the
first year or two of this organization
the Yale Daily News said that more yalie
signed up for hockey elk haces than have
ever graduated from the computer science
department in its entire history tell us
more about this program why you started
it what what were you hoping to impact
to be and what has actually happened
yeah absolutely so you know the amazing
part about that quote is that happened
in the first two weeks of the class so
hacky Oh was actually started in the
spring of my 1l year at Yale and it was
started like a very practical exigency
which was that people some small number
of people in some small group that
figured out that I had spent the past
four years building things and so I was
very frequently propositioned about hey
can you build this can you build this
can you build this it's just not very
scalable so decided to start teaching
people so in the spring of I guess we're
just trying to outsource yeah pretty
much exactly yeah so spring of 2010 I
was just me and five other like mostly
undergrads in one law school student in
a room and then that summer decided to
start institutionalizing it reached out
to a friend named Bay gross who is now
google and asked if you wanted to help
me out and we were joined by a third
who's now one of my colleagues drive
miles Grimshaw also heal undergrad and
we we posted in a semi provocative way
in fact our poster said where's Yale
Zuckerberg which was speaks to actually
the motivations of starting it which was
to sort of bootstrap the like hacker
ecosystem on campus and we had you know
almost a third of the campus undergrad
student body apply to us in two weeks
that fall
and in terms of I guess lasting impact
can you speak a little bit too you know
where where people have gone from that
program or and where's the program man
today yeah absolutely so our proudest
moment was actually last fall and Yale
finally started offering an Android
course because when we were there
president Levin was pretty excited about
what we were doing and you know
unfortunately we weren't able to sort of
you know work our curriculum into the
broader curriculum of the school but
we're hoping that over time we would
migrate in that direction so I think
very broadly speaking whatever small
part we played in like sort of steering
you know the ship towards some more
practical technologies you know I think
that is you know one part of the legacy
we're really proud of beyond that it's
still you know one of the most vibrant
largest student groups on campus and has
minted a lot of great developers that
have gone to work in a lot of Drive
portfolio companies so it's it's been a
great it's not a great journey have you
found yells Zuckerberg not sure and so
Jonathan you've been on the inside of
many different startups and helps see
five of them through successful exits
which is kind of a ridiculous track
record that's amazing considering the
vast majority of startups are expected
to fail so what do you think has been
the common theme there has it been a
were you convinced that each of these
startups when you join them we're going
to be something big or was it more about
the execution was it all you really
hellas at you I got lucky my very first
start up a video game company early 90s
before the web based on AI and doing
some innovative things i had just some
of the best people I've ever worked with
still to this day the smartest people I
know and I think I got lucky by just
having an opportunity to go there for
four years we exited during that
timeframe the web burst onto the scene
but for me they you know that what start
they're in which was common were two
things one pioneering or innovating new
categories either as a whole category or
as a specific product often highest risk
but i think that epitomizes the
attraction of a certain DNA people that
are trying to turn that dream into
reality but it's really the people for
me the team is always the starting point
the ending point and you know if you can
find people that raise your own game
that you know you're out of your comfort
zone me startups require an unreasonable
amount of effort it's something that you
can't ask you a manager can't ask it of
you or demanded of you and I find that
it's when people want to work you know
beyond what you know anybody would
expect because they they care about the
people they work with and they want to
do their part they don't want to let
people down so when you there's that
respect and that teamwork to me that's
where the great things happen so I
always looked for teams and cultures
that had that thereafter and I think I
continued to get pretty lucky I
certainly worked hard this may be a good
segue into how you invest in companies
then you told us how you pick companies
you've worked for is there a similar
theme in terms of how you look at
companies you invest in yeah absolutely
sir there's an art and a science to that
you know sure will attest to I think for
me the the science is the numbers part
you know is the opportunity large enough
all the economics and attributes of it
and then the art is the people side and
that kind of the quality that you're
going to have to calibrate and evaluate
yourself but you know there are three
things that that I look for you know in
a pitch you know first is the reason why
does somebody start a company and I've
found by far best results when somebody
has a real pain point themselves and
they come up with a great solution for
it and then they have just utter
conviction to go you know make it happen
will stop at nothing you know completely
committed the universe aligns behind
that versus people that decide let's be
founders and we're let we have a
solution in search of a problem as fine
a clear pain point and a clear solution
at
on set you're ahead of the game so
that's one thing the reason for starting
at the second is the DNA of the people
and I call it I look for business
athletes and they don't have to be
athletes beforehand sometimes they are
frequently they are not always but some
of those same qualities in the workplace
of you know the willingness to put in
the time to Train to just to work hard
to prepare you know finessing all the
details teamwork and a teamwork
mentality a intense competitive drive
and you know it's leading by example you
know more less ego and more humility but
you know hunger so that's the DNA side
and then the last the last piece and
actually things the most important is
communication when so many pitches if
they can keep it short you have my
attention I think the ability to express
yourself succinctly is it's very
indicative of time efficiency how people
make decisions you know if you can have
a meeting and make a great decision in
ten minutes not 60 the amount of stuff
you can get done as a company and how
much people enjoy that is is really high
so you know those are some things that
might be outside of what we all read
about well I think you have some
interesting things here to say as well
so thrive not only invests in companies
but also start some and you've been a
co-founder of two of the companies that
you started right can you tell us a
little bit more about those companies
and then also how you look at starting
companies versus how you look at
investing them yeah absolutely so I you
know we've now started three companies I
thrive we recently announced the third
one a company called cadre which is a
real estate finance company the first
one Oscar which anyone who lives in New
York probably knows because we've
blanketed the city and advertising is
the health insurance company and at the
time we weren't explicitly in the
business of starting companies it happen
you know rather accidentally and I think
what we've found is that you know
there's a lot of disadvantages to be
doing this when you're in your you know
mid to late 20s or now 30 but one
advantages a lot of the best
entrepreneurs are actually your peers
and so we have people in our networks
you are unbelievably talented who have
great ideas or interested in in spaces
that we're interested in and you know we
have honestly just tried to empower
those people it's been largely our
approach so with Oscar you know we did
start the company but you know to
co-ceos in the early days Kevin Azimi
and Mario schlosser were were absolutely
instrumental I'm still are to building
that company with with maple which
coming soon we you know went out pitch
David Chang and said hey David we think
your your business could have a better
margin structure it could be much more
scalable he agreed and we had already
teamed up with a guy named Caleb Merkel
and akshay novel a actually two people
you probably know from from primary and
three of them have really been going
after it together so for us you know
particularly as the market gets
increasingly inflated from the venture
perspective rates are so low and more
more money into VC and so on just going
earlier and earlier and earlier made
sense and we've been very fortunate now
to to get three great companies off the
ground and hopefully more more to come
and so those are the companies that
you've started what about the companies
that you invest in what do you look for
generally and it's there a common thesis
or themes that you look for yeah this is
this is always the hardest question and
you know one thing i love about venture
is that i've never been part of
pursuit in my life where the learning
curve has remained too steep for so long
you know now going on four and a half
years in sure it's not very long but you
start usually to feel like you hanging
something when you do it 24 hours a day
for four and a half years and with
venture I think it takes a long time to
really know if you're doing it right so
in the early days it wasn't really so
much like what to invest in it was what
not to invest in and we take these
pitches and people would come in with
these ideas that were so cool and so
innovative and I would like call up a
friend and on the farm and say hey did
you meet this guy what he's doing seems
so cool he'd be like oh yeah we passed a
long time ago how did you pass on that
like that was so cool and you still they
learned that you there's like certain
things that you have to really hone in
on so for us you know it's sort of
projecting opportunities into broadly
like a five dimensional space that we
sort of used to qualify things which is
you know we like businesses with deep
moats big market sizes we look for
amazing managers and you named a lot of
great criteria for for those managers we
look for really good margin structures
because otherwise it's going to require
way too much capital to to build those
businesses and then the last one which
you mentioned in almost a different way
which was the motivation of the
entrepreneur is the motivation of the
market which is like the Y now of the
business and if you can't point to one
there's usually a reason for that and
when you hear people say oh mobiles
Mobile's huge what they're really saying
is that mobile is like you know the
enabling technology of so many new
companies that couldn't have existed
before so Mobile has been like one of
the great why now is the past five years
and many more to come so those are the
five that we look for and you mentioned
that part of part of the learning curve
for you has been learning what not to
invest in is there such a thing as an
easy no or their red flags that you
but kind of make you go no way for both
of you yes ok can you shame that you
know I think if you you know I'm some of
the things I will said if there's not a
clearly defined audience that's a no if
there's not enough differentiation like
is your offerings your product or
service better and different by enough
that's you know it's not know if you
know it you know it's like is is the
opportunity real can you win and is it
worth it so that's another interesting
dimension which is let's say you succeed
does this business you know make sense
like do your expenses scale along with
your revenues no matter how big you get
that's not that interesting so you know
there's there's a lot of just the
business fundamentals that people get
passionate about an idea and it's a can
be a great idea and sometimes even a
great feature or product but not always
a great business yeah i think so i wrote
thought I think those are great points
and you know I guess I don't have too
much add in terms of why we say no but
actually why we're sort of reticent to
say no to quickly a lot of times which
is and you think about when I favorite
quotes about ventures the Mike Martz
quote about bird-watching and he talks
about how he doesn't bet on flocks he
bets on birds he also doesn't redline
neighborhoods and he's looking for he
puts an interestingly complected bird
and I think that it's just always
something very important to keep in mind
because you know one easy answer it be
we don't bet on small markets but
there's like endogeneity between
business models and innovation and
market size and so you know a lot of
people have looked at Google bursaries
and valuations and I'm not going to
comment on like too high or too low or
whatever but you know they will point to
the global taxi market and say
a how can you possibly justify this
valuation given the whatever it's a
hundred billion dollars spent total but
then you look at uber in San Francisco
and you say it's actually grown the
market significantly and so if you had
said overs a black car service you would
have missed it and if you would instead
said uber is going to be the urban
transportation layer of the next 50
years you would think of it very
differently so i guess for us we only
say no if there's really red flags about
about people and we're very big on
humility so that's probably you know one
one thing that robs us really wrong as
we get people coming in and and there's
not really a personality fit that being
said there have been some great CEOs who
are necessarily people be your best
friends so I think we always try to keep
an open mind have you ever heard of a
Harvard grad talking about humility like
that y'all got to just teasing okay so
the the topic of our panel is really
invested in transformation right so
let's talk about some bigger broader
themes that we like and are interested
in 44 Liberty City Avengers my fund as
rich mentioned part of part of what we
invest in is is Bitcoin and blockchain
technologies we think there's a lot of
potential there not just for Bitcoin as
a digital currency but all the different
ways that the blockchain can be used for
information authentication contracts and
ownership rights and things like that
what areas get you guys excited right
now what do you think is coming in the
future that's going to be really big
that you want to pour a lot of money
into sure so we've we've done a lot of
stuff and sort of on-demand services and
I guess that would broadly be maple
insta card and an Oscar actually it's
sort of an unsung part of Oscars teladoc
and being able to get a doctor on the
phone in in two seconds a lot of
interesting stuff continuing to happen
there I'm personally really interested
in
the advent of much cheaper and more
flexible AI and machine augmented
intelligence seeing a lot of really cool
cool companies in that space these days
sort of broadly two ways people are
coming at it one is sort of a I as a
service which is like cheap like
scalable IQ from machines and most
entrepreneurs going after that or taking
you know maybe a family of related
problems or applications and going sort
of you know BDD business to developer
and saying hey why don't you take our
our you know infrastructure and layer it
into the fabric of your apps to enhance
them and then you know perhaps even more
interesting we're seeing a lot of really
cool point solutions so companies that
are taking a very sort of deep learning
approach to solving a specific problem
and one really cool one is calendaring
and to have wrote administrative tasks
so a couple of companies one here in New
York called Xai it's a really cool
company and another called Clara labs
out west both great products and we
we've used both of them to thrive you
know we are seeing a lot in medical
diagnostics and you know there's like
one theory that you know within the next
ten years who knows maybe five years so
a lot of that diagnosis which have been
entirely at home via home diagnostics
tools and then just data and computation
and I'd love to see even more in the
space I mean I was at the office to like
2am last night modeling out what
hopefully will be the next five years
for a company that we just put put a
term sheet in on and and I I don't know
why I'm still building that model right
there's so much data that is catalog on
so many machines about so many companies
that are relevant to it and you know
there should be a way to sort of like
interpolate among all the outcomes that
have happened and produce something that
I couldn't produce in
you know a month's work in just a few
seconds so I think about so many ways in
which like I can be made obsolete or I
can at least be made smarter one of the
other one sounds better than the other
and you know I'm really excited to see
where it all goes awesome like all that
stuff I think there are two things I'll
speak about that launched capital has
played a lot in and that we look for one
we internally call unsexy industries and
how data and technology are helping
transform and just modernize industries
that are critical which could be food
production it could be agriculture it
could be waste it could be you know
things in you know supply chains that
you know haven't been modernized and
simply the awareness and efficiency and
sometimes AI but usually it's it's just
analytics can can bring so much to the
table we have company called series
imaging of aerial photography that helps
farmers know where where water is needed
you know where's nitrogen concentrated
to be smarter with their resources
important in California right now we
know we have similar monitoring
technology platforms you know in
landfill and waste our company called
the comp ology that can detect methane
detection and the old world you know
pockets are few and far between but
usually there's a lot of benefit when
when they you know kind of get the
gospel of data so that's one and then
another is and personally my own you
know thesis includes things that make
the world a better place you know that
there is healthy lifestyle and embedded
technology which could be wearables it
just could be you know data and
technology where it's actionable and
it's not data for data sake I heard that
in the last session but the things that
can keep you safer keep make you
healthier save you time
I love those things and you know so we
have several companies in that sphere or
even just innovative uses of things like
solar you know we have a company called
empowered that is an inflatable solar
panel LED lantern it's a you know comes
as a disc you inflate it and it's the
coolest life and when I saw it i'm a
product i felt that i touch them like
this is awesome a champion did you know
we invested and it's going great it's an
amazing company for not just as a
commercial success it happens to be a B
Corp benefits corporation and you know a
great mission to help disaster relief
developing countries with you know light
critical resource so or even camping I
have one oh good didn't know all right I
think that's all the time we had thank
you so much for joining us